bonjour à tous peuvent d internet vidéo
numéro 19 de ces calendriers de l'avent
on approche du but et oui je ne sais pas
pourquoi je parle comme ça mais je parle
comme ça aujourd'hui je vous présente
non pas un non pas deux non pas trois
non pas quatre mais si en fait 4-4 jeu
aujourd'hui j'ai décidé de vous parler
quatre jeux ça aurait été compliqué de
faire une vidéo pour chacun de ces jeux
par contre je trouvais qu'ils avaient un
sens à en parler ensemble dans ces
petites idées de cadeaux de noël
potentiel dans les jeux que je me suis
procuré ce que j'aime beaucoup ce que je
trouve juste sympa et ce que j'aime
moins bien et bien ce que j'aime bien je
n'en parle pas ça n'a pas tellement
d'intérêt
on commence avec le jeu de guillaume
pley même pas cap
alors en passe mentir c'est guillaume
qui me l'envoyer directement je n'ai pas
acheté
c'est un jeu de 250 défi à jouer entre
amis de 2 à 6 joueurs
ce sont des défis simple très simple
exemple concret défis stupides envoie
une grimace de toit par mms guillaume
envoie toujours des mms défi stupide
mais un doigt dans ton et puis dans ta
bouche défi physique le premier
quittèrent la lumière gagnent un point
tous les joueurs doivent ramener un
objet commençant par un ace bon on est
clairement sur un jeu ludique basique
pas se mentir c'est hyper basique
ça peut être très bien aussi pour des
adolescents maintenant on n'est pas sur
la révolution des jeux qu'on soit bien
d'accord c'est un jeu fun il fait le job
tu sais c'est un peu comme les
commentaires que tu as sur certains
produits sur amazon où il ya marqué
conforme la description basse et ça
c'est pas un jeu révolutionnaire mais
c'est conforme à la description c'est
tout à fait ce qu'on attendait de ce jeu
c'est le jeu de guillaume pley ya dans
la description
on a donc en deuxième jeu le jeu de
topito qui
a fait ça et loïc qui cadrent cette
vidéo et la menthe viens de me rappeler
quand on en a parlé dans la vidéo 5 donc
je fais ici
par contre celle dont j'ai pas parlé
c'est le jeu de siros north et thomas
guitare qui s'appelle tu imagines si qui
est sorti chez qui d'ailleurs chez
marabout
si vous n'avez pas vu la vidéo de
présentation je vous le mets dans la
description
c'est une des meilleures vidéos de
présentation de j'ai vu pour un
lancement de jeu de youtube heures ils
ont eu un super concept qui se passe en
deux temps il ya toujours un temps et si
et après il faut compléter avec une
carte bas et ça me rappelle un petit peu
le jeu blanc manger coco parce qu'il
faut faire la meilleure proposition
exemple concret imagine si c'était
interdit de s'asseoir
bah je me présenterai aux élections
présidentielles a par exemple ça se
marie pas très bien et vous devez
trouver une meilleure mariage et après
et c'est là où ça devient intéressant
contrairement aux autres jeux il faut
argumenter donc il faut avoir une
argumentation solide sur pourquoi votre
lien est meilleur qu'un autre lien et on
a testé sa est en fait la partie elle
dérive parce que on prend le truc hyper
au sérieux et on se met à avoir un vrai
argument terre à trouver des solutions
pour que ça fonctionne et tout c'est un
jeu de créativité pure la règle paraît
simple au départ et elle l'est mais
c'est aussi la difficulté de faire des
bons jeux s'est trouvé une règle simple
tu imagines si de siros north thomas
guilard bien la description et 4e jeu du
jour apéro la vache qui tâche
cette invitation est l'incroyable la
vache qui tâche j'avais pris ce jeu
parce que j'avais un jeu quand on était
petits qu'était la vache qui tâche avec
un bouchon on le brûle et on se faisait
des tâches sur le front il fallait être
la vache qui tâche et qui a deux tâches
appelle la bâche qui tâche sans tache et
c'est à elle promis qu'ils se trompaient
avait un gage et comme on y jouait
plutôt une période jeunes adultes les
gars j'étais souvent alcoolisés donc
quand j'ai vu le titre j'ai dit oh
[ __ ] super et où je vais parce qu'ils
en ont fait alors en fait on peut y
rejouer avec ces règles là un petit peu
mais c'est vraiment un jeu de questions
de culture générale et de petits défis
ça reste un jeu marrant je considère que
c'est plus un jeu à offrir qu'un jeu à
s'offrir
voilà vous en parler parce que je me
suis comme je fais un package de jeu
dont fait parler je le mets là dedans
pour vous présenter bien dans la
description
c'était une vidéo rapide ont parlé un
petit peu de jeu ça m'a fait plaisir de
vous voir j'espère que vous allez bien
on se donne rendez vous demain 6h du
matin pour la vingtième ouverture de ce
calendrier de l'avent leaké abonnez vous
restez vous mêmes
couvrez-vous il fait froid ciao
[Musique]
oh